this video will help you understand how
blood pressure is controlled in your
body
blood pressure is the amount of force
caused by blood pressing against the
walls of your arteries it is tightly
controlled to ensure sufficient blood
reaches all parts of your body arteries
are blood vessels that carry blood away
from your heart to your tissues this
blood supplies your tissues with the
oxygen and nutrients they need to
function in your heart there are two
lower chambers called ventricles which
contract with each heartbeat the right
ventricle pushes oxygen poor blood to
your lungs to pick up oxygen and the
left ventricle pushes oxygen-rich blood
through your arteries to your body
as blood flows through your arteries
four main factors affect the pressure on
the artery walls the first is the amount
of blood your ventricles push out of
your heart each minute also known as
cardiac output your blood pressure goes
up as cardiac output increases
the second factor affecting your blood
pressure is the total amount of blood in
your body or blood volume blood pressure
also goes up at blood volume increases
the third factor that affects your blood
pressure is resistance resistance is
anything working against the blood flow
through your arteries
resistance is mainly affected by the
width of your arteries your body is able
to increase the width of your arteries
to lower your blood pressure
or it can reduce the width to raise your
blood pressure
the fourth factor that affects your
blood pressure is viscosity viscosity is
how thick your blood is in your blood
more particles such as proteins and fat
increase viscosity if your blood is
thicker your blood pressure goes up as
your heart works harder to push it
through your arteries
if you have questions about high blood
pressure or any medications you have
been prescribed speak with your doctor
it is important to take your medications
as directed and report any side effects
you have